[Musique]
tous les ans les mêmes visages déchiré
par l'effort
les mêmes foule agglutinée sur le bord
des routes
le tour de france c'est un village de
4500 personnes
2400 véhicules et 35 km de câbles une
transhumance qui balaye la france durant
trois semaines en juillet depuis plus de
100 ans
derrière la petite reine et l'exploit
sportif
une superproduction qui met tant celle
des centaines d'entreprises de médias de
sponsors et de collectivités locales
chaque année des centaines de communes
candidates pour accueillir le tour
malgré des tickets d'entrée toujours
plus élevés et des cahiers des charges
toujours plus complexes
quelles sont les retombées du tour pour
les collectivités
comment se prépare l'événement sportif
de l'année sur les routes de france pour
sa 100e édition longer dans les
coulisses du tour
[Musique]
il est 5h ce 3 juillet 2013 le
ronflement des moteurs réveil
l'hippodrome borély à marseille tu
commence ici
le finish line c'est la ligne d'arrivée
pour toi
[Musique]
comme tous les matins le ballet des
équipes du tour de france est déjà en
scène pour cette 5e étape
la rade s'éveille et le chef d'orchestre
c'est jean louis pagès sous ses ordres
200 personnes plusieurs nationalités
comme ça oui les caméras d'accord c'est
parfait
merci vous pouvez installer le camion
sur le côté pas de problème bonne
journée
sa passion ce n'est pas le vélo mais
l'organisation enlever les plombs pour
est salée les tribunes
mais c'était prévu c'est que si l'engin
est là c'est que c'était prévu c'est pas
céder c'est pas compliqué
monsieur veut absolument que ce soit
compliqué c'est pas compliqué c'est du
vélo c'est un mécano en juillet voitures
et des camions et appeler les gens sont
gentils
[Musique]
jean plus constant que moi mais bon faut
de morgen
dans moins de douze heures maintenant
les coureurs passeront la ligne
d'arrivée tribu une salle de presse car
régie tout doit être monté avant midi
alors pour les équipes de la ville de
marseille et du tour c'est un peu
l'heure contre la montre
[Musique]
après vous avoir dit bonjour et
bienvenue à marseille je je je vous on
n'est pas en retard
mes gars on se fout tout la pression la
course n'arrive qu'à 5 heures
pardon 17 heures on a le temps on a le
temps pour eve pour que vous glisse pour
que vous puissiez aller dormir
cette année à 57 ans et son 30ème tour
de france
alors ils connaissent la mécanique et il
sait qu'il doit dorloter ses équipes
c'est un travail d'orfèvre que nous
faisons même si ce matin ça a pu vous
choquer dans l'enlèvement de ces plots
mais c'était prévu pas de question pas
de souci bonne journée
on sait la volonté des élus simplement
ce que les élus ne connaissent pas
honteux que les représentants des
collectivités ou des stations notre
ordinateur
c'est ça c'est ce bazar laquelle a
derrière elle et qu'on a besoin sur une
arrivée d'étape de 7 hectares de surface
ici à marseille pour dames aurélie on
est tout à fait dedans sur un départ
d'étape c'est entre 3 et 4 ha donc avec
une surface nécessaire donc là aussi il
faut le volume pour le village du tour
et il faut des structures d'accueil pour
une salle de presse et différents
éléments
ça nous le savons à nous de marier ses
contraintes techniques avec la volonté
des élus donc trouver le bon coup le bon
compromis entre les deux tout est
conforme n'y a pas de soucis simplement
il faut qu'on comprenne que le tour de
france et le tour de france en fait et
qu'il a 7
cette particularité c'est normal d'être
itinérant alors c'est vrai que ça peut
paraître le bazar on peut dire après
tout ce qu'on veut mais c'est un bazar
qui est organisée cette ligne d'arrivée
c'est l'aboutissement de huit mois de
travail avec les collectivités
après la présentation du tour fin
octobre jean-louis sillonne la france à
la rencontre des élus bilan plus de 80
réunions 120 mille kilomètres 200 nuits
à l'hôtel
et pour cet ancien professeur d'histoire
géographie beaucoup de pédagogie
je pense que dans mon boulot si voilà
que les élus quand l'arrivée à lyon se
regardant dans les yeux lance un clin
d'oeil et c'est bon on sait que ça a
marché et on reviendra et on peut
revenir d'où la nécessité d'avoir un
discours franc clair précis cash
pour les collectivités le passage du
tour de france est une aubaine la
meilleure opération de communication
possibles pour un territoire
mais accueillir une étape cela un prix
soixante dix mille euros pour un départ
90000 pour une arrivée
pourtant chaque année plus de 250 villes
sont candidates
y compris à l'étranger même tokyo
souhaite accueillir la grande boucle
c'est christian prudhomme qui dessine
chaque année le parcours directeur du
tour depuis 2005 cet ancien journaliste
sportif se frottent désormais aux
politiques le tour de france repose sur
trois piliers le pied sportif bien sûr
mais aussi un pilier esthétique
touristique qu'est mise en valeur et
magnifié par la télévision les images
sont absolument somptueuse et on l'a
sans doute vu plus encore qu'à
l'ordinaire avec le départ de ce tour de
france de cette 100e édition du tour de
france nous nous étions pour la première
fois en corse
et puis il ya un autre aspect qui est le
pilier social du tour de france au bord
des routes du tour
vous avez des familles les gens qui ont
le sourire vous avez les anciennes dans
les maisons de retraite les gamins
devant les centres aérés le club de
vacances on y va en famille en hiver ses
copains donc ces essais ont il ya des
français il ya des étrangers
il ya toutes les catégories sociales
donc c'est cet ensemble là qui fait le
succès du tour de france qui est une
épreuve à nul autre pareil sans aucun
doute
[Musique]
le tour de france fait le troisième
événement sportif au monde après les
jeux olympiques et la coupe du monde de
football
190 pays retransmettre la grande boucle
donc les cinq continents il est en haute
définition depuis 2007
il ya donc cinq motos au sol deux
hélicos on arrose caméras sur le site
d'arrivée et donc qui filme donc les
derniers kilomètres de la course et
quelques caméras ensuite au niveau du
protocole pour les interviews et
quelques ambiances
il arrive que nous ayons quelques
personnes à marseille derrière la ligne
d'arrivée des dizaines de cars régie des
télévisions belges allemands
néerlandaise australienne ou américaine
à l'avant de la course
il va de nouveau pour cette 100e édition
2000 journalistes sont accrédités il ya
toute une partie de notre public qui
n'est là qui je pense peut à peine cité
le vainqueur du jour mais qui est là
pour regarder ce spectacle est à quai la
france et cp 10 et ses paysages il ya
une étude que j'ai vu il ya quelques
années et qui disait que l'audience au
danemark se reprend le danemark était
composée jusqu'à 30% de femmes de plus
de 50 ans qui n'était là que pour ça
équidés pour le coup incapable à ce que
la question a été posée dans l'étude
qu'il des pour le coup incapable de
citer le vainqueur du tour ou qui était
le porteur du maillot jaune etc
c'était vraiment pour se faire plaisir
s'asseoir passer un bon après midi d'été
et regarder la france et ses paysages
voilà qui sont rendus mais
merveilleusement par la production dans
les sols et france télévisions
qui dit tour de france dix cartes
postales alors chaque collectivité
fournit aux organisateurs un descriptif
précis des monuments et paysages que le
spectateur découvre sur son écran on a
un bouc qui fait à peu près 300 pages
qui est distribué à tous les
commentateurs qui soient sur place quand
l'étranger qui explique site par site
étape par étape quelle en est l'histoire
qu'elle en ait larchitecture quelle est
la région quel est son nom quelles sont
ses spécificités et ses essais de ces la
bible
les commentateurs en sont fans aient eux
mêmes après une plein de choses on a on
en fait les gens qui est quasiment plus
spécialiste de la france que nous il
aurait cherché les calanques de cassis
vois la magnifique hd à l'antenne
toujours fin de l'étape mark cavendish
passe la ligne d'arrivée en tête
219 km sous un soleil de plomb et sur le
podium c'est monsieur le sénateur-maire
qui salue les vainqueurs à coeur de
cette étape daniel c'est la 35e fois
dans l'histoire du tour que le tour
s'arrête à marseille
les retombées sont extraordinaires parce
que vous le voyez il ya une foule qui
réunit les gens sont heureux c'est la
fête
et pour une fois on parle en bien de
marseille et pas du bashing auquel on
est habitué dans les médias parisiens le
tour tout le monde y gagne c'est un
partenariat subtil entre élus et
organisateurs sa part d'élus qui nous
dit oui pour une grille de départ
un élu qui dit oui pour avoir une vie
l'arrivée
nous ne pouvons pas faire grand chose
d'autant que nous sommes nous sommes
sûrs à les 98 et demi pour cent de
routes départementales ou dépendants des
conseils généraux sans l'aval des élus
on peut pas faire de parcours mission
accomplie demain ex montpellier
à aix en provence ce matin du 4 juillet
séjour de départ au village les terroirs
sont à l'honneur les partenaires du tour
aussi ici entre deux bouchées de
calissons la communication est reine
alliès goujat est une femme pressée
depuis 15 ans c'est elle qui gère les
délicats rapport avec les politiques et
les collectivités pour le tour de france
est ce que tu peux pour la ville de
daigle et la communauté du pays d'aix
signé un panneau s'il te plaît certes
cette saison leur je suis ok je sais
bien que tu es outils et je suis non ils
veulent aller
régine ça va aller soigner les relations
avec les institutions c'est la mission
première d'agnès alors ça vaut bien une
signature de raymond poulidor la fed à
londres un génial c'est terrible la
maman dans toutes les mains des verts et
tous ces anniversaires dans son édition
de manger des galiciens de bonheur nous
on se fait la bise parce que c'est dans
vingt minutes comme tous les matins il
faut organiser la cérémonie protocolaire
objectif remercié les élus un exercice
de haute voltige qui nécessite un brin
de diplomatie surtout quand les
discordes politique invite sur scène il
est là mais on le croit pas
je préfère te dire il se peut qu'ils
montent de fort et là on pourra rien
faire d'autre
c'est pas vous qui l'avait invité
d'accord il ya des buts et qui est
présent qui ont habité mais qui est pas
du même bord politique et dont aucune
envie de la voir sur le podium
donc on le prend pas mais quand il va
entendre la cérémonie protocolaire qui
va voir qui va l'invité surprise c'est
jean david ciot député ps des bouches du
rhône
c'est lui qui a battu maryse joissains
masini la maire d'aix-en-provence aux
législatives bonjour madame agnès
gougeat se travailler avec une équipe en
toute l'année mais malheureusement
travail est d'ailleurs à écouter c'est
une réussite
j'avais supplée la belle rigueur et la
menace qu'ils ont pris l'habitude ça va
être une exigence pourquoi ah bon voilà
les bleus pendant mon directeur le plus
beau cadeau qu'on puisse le faire c'est
que les collectivités qui travaillent
ensemble sur le dossier du tour très
travaillé main dans la main après pour
ceux dont les dossiers mal à rester
mobilisés
salamix nommé dans l'excès leur choix
l'excellent score
or elle va dans les statuts
c'est une excellente très dense et merci
beaucoup le chabada c'est le tour de
france
l'adolescence clémence tu peux venir
parce qu'on a 50 personnes sur podium
c'est l'heure de la cérémonie
protocolaire et comme prévu le député
sur le podium mais les apparences sont
sauves
la photo de famille est belle et lui
aussi aura droit à son cadeau
l'objectif à quelques mois des
municipales faire des élus des alliés du
tour
et qu'importe le bord politique le tour
est une énorme galerie commerciale
certaines entreprises en profitent pour
faire du lobbying auprès des élus
d'autres invitent leurs clients à suivre
la course l'organisation du tour aussi à
ses invités souvent des politiques et
les habite et qu'on retrouve sur place
les différents seront sur place puis
après il ya ce qu'on l'a fait vite
qu'ils viennent en avion
c'est directement du bourget ça peut
être n'importe en pensant peut être la
porte
évidemment c'est pas n'importe qui mais
ça peut être les présidents de nos
partenaires ça peut être un ministre
madame annie des sports est venu dans un
avion du tout par exemple en revanche le
ministre des transports avait un
déplacement à faire encore ce qui est
voulu par ses propres moyens il appelle
étapes et delahaye les laisse travailler
on a tous les cas de figure nous avons
les boutiques officielles de produits du
tour mais après depuis quelques années
le métier d'agnès a changé et le mille
feuille institutionnel y est pour
beaucoup
auparavant les conventions avec le tour
était signée en majorité par les villes
aujourd'hui les interlocuteurs se sont
multipliés région département
agglomération
la décentralisation est passée par là ça
peut faire vous continuez à terre deux
conventions et puis maintenant on a des
cas très particuliers quelquefois il ya
un conseil général qui va prendre en
charge complètement le ticket d'entrée
pour une ville la ville va s'occuper
tout tout l'aménagement technique la
mise à disposition des barrières va
faire le sud et frais de communication
peut-être et tout ça mais le ticket
d'entrée était payé par par le cancer et
du coup ils vont vouloir avoir la
mainmise sur tout les accréditations les
colzas voilà il faut jongler en
permanence entre eux et puis quelquefois
ils travaillent ensemble pour le dossier
mais ne se parle pas on soit des fois
des mails où on lui dit ah non mais je
leur adresse pas la parole
faut que ça passe par 46 ans donc c'est
dommage c'est c'est d'autant plus
dommage que j'ai connu la période où
société complètement fédérateur tous les
jours agnès fait l'étape derrière la
caravane
les siens pour dire bonjour à la
sampdoria tri ace qui la choralité massa
n'a pas d'amis c'est la caravane ses 180
véhicules 37 marque et 15 millions
d'objets distribué sur le bord des
routes
un événement attendu des spectateurs 47%
ne viennent que pour cela
mais pendant les 165 kilomètres de
l'étape le téléphone continue de sonner
encore et toujours le protocole de
l'équipe et tout ça donc vous n'avez pas
à vous inquiéter de sa d'accord accepté
la loi oui oui vient à fougères le 11
mai oui on invite à dépasser pas une
on est en bretagne c'est que ça tout le
temps c'est que ça tout le temps
aujourd'hui agnès fait une halte au
relais étape sur le parcours entre la
ville départ et l'arrivée ce village
éphémère est aussi dédié aux partenaires
du tour ici les invités peuvent regarder
passer la caravane les coureurs et
photographié des légendes vivantes
bernard hinault bernard thévenet raymond
poulidor ses anciens coureurs font
partie de l'organisation de la grande
boucle
objectif permettre aux clients aux élus
de tutoyer quelques instants ces mythes
de leur enfance oh la la qu'est ce
qu'elle est belle
j'ai dit aujourd'hui
a très bien marché c'est un vrai
collectionneur saïda des maillots des
des anciens champions
les refait un visage
bonjour madame si vous passez une bonne
journée j'ai chanté agnès couchage
m'occupe des relations avec les
collectivités et pour les villes départ
et les villes arrivent mais vous
souhaitez le vous avez tout l'avantagé
de recevoir les aides arriver là mais
c'est pas sûr alors je voudrais vous
remettre avant que vous partiez mêmes
diplômes que vous avez bien mérité mais
elle est bien chaude hier agnès à 6 à
6,6 à passer oui ça me touche ça me
touche beaucoup parce que j'ai une vraie
tendresse pour les anciens coureurs et
et en particulier pour charlie gaulle et
voit comme charlie est décédé ce à son
épouse et sa fille grandit mais
t'inquiète pas dieu c'est toujours avec
avec lui et elles ont mis ma photo dans
son cercueil
donc voilà qu'à voir ce tableau ça me
rappelle quelque chose
merci beaucoup et rationnelle petites
sommes mais lente par la glace bon
travail dans père chez aso dont patrice
khodja bonjour alors c'est vous
champions patrick aux autres vous voulez
pas changé par rapport au je vais aller
retrouver mes interlocuteurs
j'espère que j'en aurai pas ce qu'il ya
à marseille j'avais pas d'élu et pas
d'interlocuteur que j'avais eue toute
l'année pour trouver les élus et
monsieur gaudin rentré de paris et on
n'était pas sûr que son avion serait à
l'heure donc c'était un petit peu
ennuyeux en fait donc tout s'est bien
arrangé banderoles panneaux barrières
sur le parcours
rien n'est laissé au hasard chaque
détail est immortalisé pour faciliter le
travail des collectivités l'année
suivante
allez un petit podium protocolaire en
plus
fin de l'étape entre aix et montpellier
les coureurs arrivent dans quelques
minutes
les élus seront sur le podium gens
pressés en charge des relations avec les
collectivités
voilà c'est moi qui vais avoir le
plaisir des clients surtout chanté
maires présidents d'agglomérations de
conseil régional tous doivent garder un
souvenir inoubliable de ce moment
partagé avec les cyclistes
ça va très vite et à monter sur tes andy
ram je vais la chercher l'aide alors
cette étape c'était bière supermarché
dia 7 président sur ce podium
hélène mandroux maire de montpellier
pause côte à côte avec son rival jean
pierre moure président de
l'agglomération
un cliché rare aujourd'hui hier mais
christian bourcart bay martin et jacques
touchon de professeurs touchons dans
quelques instants elle vient demanderons
bien sûr maire de montpellier jean
pierre moure président de la communauté
d'agglomération de montpellier et une
journée réussie pour agnès qui aura
réuni les nombreux représentants des
collectivités sur une même scène
[Musique]
souvent à l'issue de l'étape les élus
offre un cocktail aux représentants du
tour de france
une manière d'oublier le protocole et de
nourrir des liens souvent amicaux entre
les organisateurs de la course et les
élus hélène mandroux la maire socialiste
de montpellier n'ait pas présente à
cette cérémonie organisée par jean
pierre moure une autre réception se
tiendra à la mairie dans quelques heures
mais tout cela n'aurait rien à voir avec
la course aux municipales la mairie
invités dont la dead etc à l'abri les
unes des autres en fait de journée à
respecter noyau comme problème par
rapport à ça
le fonctionne très bien avec les
représentants de la mairie avec mon âme
vendres où j'étais avec elle il n'y a
pas de problème aucun problème de ce
côté-là la compétition électorale est un
exercice démocratie c'est salutaire
nous n'aurons aucun problème par rapport
à ces questions we dance alone c'est au
tour de france
un spécial pour les collectivités le
réveil on est habitué à jouer ce genre
de match est gagné
ce matin on part de la place de la
comédie à montpellier
le tour c'est 12 millions de spectateurs
sur le bord des routes
c'est l'un des derniers grands
spectacles sportifs populaire et gratuit
les cyclistes se sont encore accessibles
disponibles près du public aux abords et
dans la course
22 équipes 198 coureurs et 34
nationalités depuis 1962 les équipes ne
sont plus nationale mais sponsorisé par
des entreprises
un investissement qui rapporte aux
sponsors mais surtout à amaury sport
organisation en 2011 à etsaut est
engrangé un bénéfice net de 32,5
millions d'euros en grande partie grâce
au tour
comme chaque matin le cortège accueille
quelques invités de marque sur l'étape
aujourd'hui c'est bernard thibault la
société présente traditionnellement est
historiquement sur le tour de france en
tant que militant et aussi en tant que
partenaire vous savez le tour de france
doit aussi sa renommée notamment en fait
qu'à concomitance entre le calendrier du
tour et les congés payés une grande
conquête sociale et de ce point de vue
là je me félicite que les organisateurs
ouvrent des petites fenêtres permettant
de relater ce qui se passe dans telle ou
telle contrée y compris sur le plan
social et vous imaginez qu'en ce moment
il ya beaucoup de choses a relaté
tous les syndicats sont représentés dans
la caravane un partenariat plus que
stratégique pour les organisateurs la
meilleure manière d'éviter les
manifestations syndicales sur le
parcours on ne bloque pas le tour de
france
et comme à l'accoutumée c'est madame le
maire qui donne le départ
[Applaudissements]
je crois que c'est un grand moment
d'émotion surtout ce qui pour moi est
très important c'est de voir le bonheur
de tous les tous les maux ou c'est non
seulement les montpelliérains et de tous
les français aussi de tous les touristes
étrangers qui sont venus pour voir le
tour j'ai donné cent mille euros
et je crois qu'il est retombé ces huit
fois deux fois dix fois plus sympas
c'est incroyable tout à l'heure ce que
me disait
christian prudhomme sur l'ensemble du
tour de france j'ai passé plusieurs
millions millions de personnes qui
regardent le tour de france c'est
exceptionnel à bagnères de bigorre dans
les hautes pyrénées
on attend la première étape de montagne
ici la grande boucle passe depuis 1910
tourmalet aspin peyresourde ses cols
mythiques ont écrit l'histoire du tour
alors entre les pyrénées et la petite
reine
c'est un tandem presque amoureux
la pratique du vélo est en pleine
ascension 22 millions de français sont
adeptes de la bicyclette depuis des
années le département des
hautes-pyrénées mise sur le
cyclotourisme pour dynamiser son
économie
ce samedi matin sur la place du village
quelques cyclistes sont attablés belge
irlandais néerlandais
ils ont franchi plusieurs cols dans la
matinée on termine ici après avoir fait
650 km la de colle et de vallées dans
une semaine on a une douzaine de cols
les plus mythiques mais alors aussi
l'école de beyrède et de cours est ce
que les coureurs ne feront jamais
d'abord parce que la caravane ne ferait
pas y passer alors sera chercher dans
lévis 12 cas force est à un maximum de
18 %
c'était pas ici ah non nous ne restons
que trois quatre jours ça ses baronnies
ce côté c'est vraiment très jolie
un mois avant le tourmalet teyssou 7
mètres de neige
quelques kilomètres plus bas des
dizaines de coureurs se prépare pour la
montée du géant
un événement qui signe le début de la
saison touristique dans les hautes
pyrénées
il est huit heures du matin et toute la
famille du cyclisme est réuni pour
honorer son col légendaire le plus
emprunté de l'histoire du tour à 75 ans
un des doyens affiche encore quinze
mille kilomètres de routes par an j'ai
bien monté 40 ou 50 fois le nom les
parce que je venais en vacances à
luz-saint-sauveur et donc le tourmalet
c'était ma
soit je partais sur la mongie et je
revenais par lourdes et je faisais mon
circuit comme ça ou à l'envers ça c'est
bien parce conviviale c'est formidable
moi j'adore
quelques courageux sont en costume et
vélos d'époque car cette année on fête
aussi le centenaire de laventure
d'eugène christophe un célèbre coureur
du tour de france et ce matin là c'est
jean marie leblanc ancien directeur du
tour qui donne le départ
[Musique]
une
c'est une star internationale il entend
aperçoit d'autant mieux leur sont créés
des événements qui amènent des cyclistes
quasiment de toute la france mais aussi
de l'étranger
aujourd'hui certains sont venus du fin
fond de l'espagne en à des australiens
l'américain par exemple est ce ce
tourmalet à un pouvoir d'attraction
extraordinaire et c'est une phase encore
une fois de nous rappeler ce qu'il
représente ce fameux paul nous qui
l'avons évidemment chez nous et qui
pourrions avoir un regard un peu détaché
au contraire grâce à cet événement
notamment de la montée du genre du
tourmalet et puis à fortiori le tour de
france lorsqu'il passe ça nous rappelle
qu'on a ici un col d'un prestige
qui dépasse nos frontières le
cyclotourisme est un gisement économique
en expansion qui est très très loin
d'avoir atteint sa maturité des
nouvelles nations émergent des nations
de l'est mer de l'hémisphère sud
notamment australiens néozélandais
sud-africain désormais affluent de plus
en plus vers les pyrénées et notamment
les hautes pyrénées avec ce col du
tourmalet qui a un pouvoir d'attraction
mais on a peine à imaginer c'est un peu
la quête du graal
le tour de france s'est construit sur
ces mythe des forçats de la route des
légendes qui dépasse les frontières
françaises et sont un levier pour
l'économie locale
le tourisme est la première activité
économique des hautes pyrénées
cela représente des milliers d'emplois
et un milliard d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires une manne indispensable pour
ce département de 230 mille habitants
nichée au creux des cols on a fait
coïncider cette année la montée du genre
du tourmalet avec le centenaire
eugène christophe faut dire que ce
centenaire correspond avec la 100e
édition du tour de france c'est une
conjonction formidable pour nous et
promotionnelles dans eugène christophe
est une grande figure du tour de france
ce coureur cas c'est la fourche de son
vélo dans la descente du tourmalet en
1913 et l'a réparé à lui-même à la forge
de sainte marie de campan à leur leader
il perd la course mais construit sa
légende
le département a donc imaginé une
reconstitution grandeur nature de cette
saga objectifs communiqués ce jour là
christian prudhomme le directeur du tour
est présent aux côtés des élus
un moment convivial qui scelle les
relations entre politiques et
responsables de la course des rapports
qui pèse lourd dans le tracé du parcours
et chaque année il passe dans les hautes
pyrénées un mois plus tard le 6 juillet
nous sommes la veille de l'étape saint
girons bagnères de bigorre accueillir le
tour de france c'est aussi assurer sa
sécurité
ici en zone rurale c'est la mission des
gendarmes
et cette année un invité de marque est
attendu sur l'étape pyrénéenne il est
officiel que le président de la
république sera sur l'étape du tour de
france dimanche
ça suppose dispositif qui vient se
greffer sur au dispositif initial du
tour de france afin de sécuriser
les déplacements
du président il faut reconnaître le
parcours du cortège présidentiel
rien n'est laissé au hasard mais
toujours répandue qu'on a dit ouais
c'est le seul problème à celui-là on
décale d'ici à la fin de cette école est
ici le décor ici non mais personne n'en
demandent aux motards de la commande et
ont demandé une équipe de motards de toi
une voiture de route
sai on aspire les années maintenant 2
mon salut qui sera pas pris mais on a
reconnu sa les termes avec le sens
interdit donc moi j'ai deux gars qui
serait allé j'avais signé tous ont fait
l'a été par rapport à son programme que
nous
nous vérifions la ligne narrative en
pointe et nous prévoyons la sécurisation
qui sera mise en place à se battre pour
que le cortège puisse progresser dans
les meilleures conditions possibles
plusieurs itinéraires sont prévues
l'escort ne doit jamais être immobilisés
sur les hauteurs de bagnères les
gendarmes ont aménagé une aire
d'atterrissage pour l'hélicoptère du
président malgré tout ce qui peut être
prévu on n'est jamais à l'abri de
de changements de situations ou d'un
problème particulier qui fait qu'on est
obligé de trouver un plan b et donc dès
que c'est prévu mais on n'a aucune
difficulté après orienter le dispositif
et d'erreurs ou l'autre des sur une
autre déviation en moyenne 24 mille
policiers et gendarmes sécurisent le
parcours du tour et chaque jour la route
est privatisée trois heures par arrêté
préfectoral pour laisser passer la
course
un partenariat qui a un coût 2 millions
d'euros sont reversés chaque année
paraissent au ministère de l'intérieur
pour la mise à disposition de ces
équipes c'est pas sur la route
d'accord d'accord parce que voilà donc
plus on vous aurait plus de place non
plus pour vous garer l'autre mission des
forces de l'ordre gérer l'afflux des
spectateurs dans les cols de montagne
cette année une seule étape traverse les
pyrénées alors les camping caristes se
sont installés très tôt il vaut mieux la
limite de garder quelques places encore
pour demain matin ouais je voulais
sérénité si tout est calme si ça bouge
pas ce pro ce soir on laisse remonter un
petit peu comment tu fais d'habitude et
déjà sur le matin ou l'après exactement
on à l'affût des jeunes qui étaient les
nôtres nous mettre le bazar avait la
nuit moi c'est le gérer comme ça et
ensuite les matins quand c'est un petit
peu plus et un peu plus calme elles
seront montées mission délicate pour le
commandant hubert six cars de crs
doivent stationner au col de la
hourquette d'ancizan pour assurer la
sécurité du président de la république
problème il faut déplacer des camping
cars installé depuis déjà plusieurs
jours
mais s'ils veulent pas partir alors dire
que de toute façon il y aura un arrêté
préfectoral qui va qui valait contrat
fera bouger dans la nuit donc que
personne n'aura rien n'est gagné qu on
aura juste perdu du temps pour le bien
de tout le monde on va essayer de faire
pour le mieux protéger les coureurs et
les personnalités
une tâche difficile on compte parfois
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
spectateurs sur les étapes de montagne
messieurs bonjour nous venons pour vous
annoncer une mauvaise nouvelle mais en
fait on vous et je vous explique il va
falloir recettes que vous vous seriez il
ya entre eux vous seriez pour laisser
plus de place à gagner là vous avez
gagné même passé pour ne pas savoir où
faire déloger
aidez nous resserrer vous au maximum et
tout se passera bien
le tour c'est vraiment quelque chose de
magique c'est une ambiance qu'on
retrouve pas dans les autres sports
c'est quelque chose de magique et
surtout quand on est camping caristes
parce que je crois qu'un tour de france
s'il n'avait pas de camping car ce
serait pas ici
le camping sauvage est interdit tout au
long de l'année mais quand le tour passe
la loi est quelque peu mis entre
parenthèses le tour de france est ici
c'est aussi le public qui fait vivre le
tour de france et c'est dans les cols
mythiques qu'on peut voir les que les
gens profitent du paysage et qu'on peut
voir le comment dire qu'on peut voir au
mieux les ford et des coureurs donc sans
je pense que c'en est sans les
spectateurs le tour de france perdrait
un petit peu sa notoriété il faut bien
qu'on laissait aux gens aussi
l'opportunité de devenir la veille pour
se positionner
et puis c'est une petite parenthèse
qu'on offre à tout le monde qui permet
de
rendre tout ça un peu un peu piquant
jour j le tour par de saint girons en
ariège direction bagnères de bigorre
hautes pyrénées
voilà on colle pas trop là parce qu'on
va arriver sur le giratoire le
rond-point de veau au pk 57
donc je vais vous dire qu'il faut mettre
je vais approcher un petit peu au petit
matin avant l'étape
ce sont les équipes des départements qui
prépare la route
nous le rôle de là le rôle de l'équipe
ce qu'on appelle la patrouille avancé de
signaler tous les points dangereux
surtout pour la caravane plus que pour
les coureurs c'est les coureurs avec les
oreillettes et sont bien sont bien au
courant de ce qui se passe mais surtout
pour la caravane qui elle circule en
double double voie donc ils ont besoin
de savoir sur les giratoires s'ils
peuvent partir des deux côtés et la
sortie c'est la droite c'est la gauche
tous les rétrécissements que dans ces
cas là il faut qu'il se remette sur une
file et puis tous les dos d'âne
c'est une superbe expérience quoi
humaine déjà parce que déjà ça nous
permet de voir des collègues d'autres
départements de discuter de nos travail
voir comment il fonctionne et puis c'est
une chaîne humaine incroyable quand on
voit des gens de différents milieux
et puis moi qui adore le sport je suis
gâté quoi sécurisation des routes
entretien des chaussées balisage si une
équipe de neuf agents permanents suis
l'intégralité du court
pas moins de 3000 fonctionnaires
départementaux sont mobilisés
au même moment à saint girons en village
départ une réunion se tient au pavillon
de l'assemblée des départements de
france à descendre la descente du portet
d'aspet
ap
c'est quand même un très bon c'est une
réunion qui est un point général sur
l'étape sur la préparation de halle est
appelée sur ce qui va se passer pendant
la journée
l'objectif c'est de faire un tour de
table avec les représentants du tour les
représentants locaux des départements
concernés
nos équipes permanentes pour vérifier
que la route est en bon état
savoir s'il faut procéder à des
dernières retouches ensuite chacun pour
la route à son échelon et on reste en
contact entre nous et on corrige les
éventuels éléments qu'on a pu développer
le matin cette année 37 départements
sont traversés par la grande boucle
et c'est l'assemblée des départements de
france qui coordonnent leurs actions
nous entends kdf ça nous permet aussi
par les contacts quotidiens qu'on a avec
les départements ce pouvoir redescendre
de l'information remontée de
l'information
donc c'est un véritablement eu
stratégique une passerelle entre le tour
de france à côté et l'ensemble des
départements concernés
quatre heures avant la course deux
agents départementaux ouvre la route
ils vérifient les installations des
équipes du matin et l'état du parcours
avant le passage de la caravane
c'est un coup de vent mais si la
rubalise se casse çà peut venir sur la
chaussée puis ça peut se prendre dans le
rayon des cyclistes donc c'est assez
dangereux
[Musique]
la patrouille technique a repéré au p 49
ça doit du liquide de refroidissement
sur la route donc contrôler vos
véhicules il ya un véhicule qui perd du
liquide de refroidissement
objectif des services de voirie un
parcours parfait pour éviter un accident
vous pourriez m'attacher à votre
bouteille d'eau sur les girondins
comptent pas et l'autre également
nouveaux sportifs l'internement en soi
du fonds de recherche mis en avant lors
des journées sur l'école nous on a pas
mal de courses cyclistes pendant toute
la période du printemps et de l'été on
va dire donc on s'acharne à maintenir
quand même des routes en état de
sécurité correct pour l'épauler cycliste
après le passage de la caravane
andré ses équipes nettoient la route sur
les 3500 kilomètres de course la
quasi-totalité des chaussées empruntés
sont des départementales alors une fois
le parcours du tour rendu public
les services de voiries des départements
se lance quand cela est nécessaire dans
la réfection des routes tarifs pour
amaury sport organisation deux cent
cinquante mille euros
la responsabilité du choix de
l'itinéraire et de son état et de la
responsabilité de l'organisateur de la
course donc d'assaut en revanche tous
derrière au titre du partenariat qu'on a
signés entre l'assemblée des
départements de france et le tour nous
avons
une tâche des tâches à accomplir ces
tâches c'est proposer un itinéraire
soignés sur lequel on a on est intervenu
pour le préparer sur lequel on
intervient pour du balisage pour de la
signalisation mais on n'a pas une
obligation de résultat ce que demande le
tour c'est essentiellement ce travail-là
de mise en place de préparation de mise
à disposition de moyens matériels
humains dans le cadre du partenariat et
puis après je gère la course les
coureurs viennent de quitter saint
girons direction bagnères de bigorre 168
km cinq cols dont quatre de première
catégorie devant la course c'est gros
léon qui ouvre la route
sa mission préparer le parcours avant le
passage des cyclistes
en gros les on a pour mission donc
travailler on travaille juste devant la
course
ensuite à la caravane beaucoup de déchet
sur la route ça arrive du gravier qui
est remis par la caravane passe qui
roulent en tient compte dans les petites
routes donc
sur les accotements nous ramène beaucoup
de graviers
on arrose aussi les plaques de ressuage
ces grosses plaques de goudron noir
quand il fait très chaud qui colle
banquier très dangereuse pour les
coureurs donc on la refroidit on emmène
et on emmène des bottes de paille pour
sécuriser les endroits quand est oubliée
voilà c'est là
principale mission de voler haut je suis
moi au pk 113,9 ressuage sur l'extérieur
donc on va faire passer un peu de flotte
dessus sur une épingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le fluorescents gros leon est un camion
prêté par le département des vosges le
seul en france
une jolie opération de communication
tout au long du tracé pour ce territoire
très peu visitée par le tour
[Musique]
au même moment la caravane publicitaire
traverse bagnères de luchon en haute
garonne
le dispositif musclée des forces de
l'ordre est en place françois hollande
vient d'arriver
le président de la république à bagnères
de luchon pour le tour de france plus
qu'un symbole pour cette ville sinistrée
quelques semaines auparavant par des
crues historiques ici certaines routes
empruntées par le tour se sont révélés
impraticables et des dizaines de
villages se sont retrouvés coupés du
monde
c'est la passerelle
l aider
là
de la crue et dont on était sur une rue
peel et de transformer un véritable
torrent de boue près et charriant des
voilà des quantités de voir des
interviews qui ont repris le lit de la
rivière donc ça va être aussi à notre
site pour la rai d'enlever voilà c'est
alors les services de voirie ont
travaillé d'arrache-pied pour accueillir
la course est montré le visage d'une
station thermale capable d'accueillir
les touristes en ce début juillet ils
sont très largement diffusés sont très
bonnes oui parce qu'elle contribue à
assurer une bonne promotion récupérer
les records d'ailleurs pour remettre en
état et est maintenant accueillir dans
les meilleures conditions les touristes
nous sommes commerçants et que nous
espérons que le touriste viendra en
masse parce que il ya une publicité
comme quoi nous étions très sinistré et
que la montagne n'était pas accessible
si il ya des sites ouverts
il faut absolument que on retrouve notre
tourisme toujours tous les présidents de
la république s'invite sur les bords du
tour françois hollande vivre à la fin de
l'étape pyrénéenne dans la voiture de
christian prudhomme le directeur de la
course
[Musique]
les coureurs entrent dans les
hautes-pyrénées avant l'arrivée à
bagnères de bigorre ils devront avaler
trois cols à plus de 7 % de dénivelé
l'irlandais daniel martin passera la
ligne d'arrivée avec plus d'une demi
heure d'avancé sur l'horaire prévu
christopher froome reste en jaune
et c'est le président de la république
qui félicite les vainqueurs du jour
[Musique]
après la course c'est le départ des
caravanes et le début du nettoyage est
une fois de plus c'est la mission des
services de voirie la grande boucle et
souvent épinglé car peu écologique 12
millions de spectateurs 2400 véhicules
3500 km et de nombreux cadeaux trop
souvent abandonné sur le bord de la
route
bilan une empreinte carbone
astronomiques
on a eu le passage sur le col de la
hourquette qui était le dernier col des
pyrénées pour ainsi dire et donc on a eu
une influence de public
c'est assez conséquente notamment en
camping-car qui serait depuis plus d'une
semaine
quoi donc bien sûr ça a généré un
certain nombre de déchets
et et on met à disposition des
containers des sacs poubelles et puis
maintenant il faut aller tout collectés
puis nettoyées pour les abords des
routes qui ont pu être un petit peu
soulier chaque étape du tour génère
entre 10 et 20 tonnes de déchets mais
pour une arrivée en montagne on culmine
parfois à 50 tonnes depuis quelques
années les organisateurs du tour cherche
à réduire cette pollution notamment
évolué on a essayé de sensibiliser un
petit peu les les
les différents publicitaires déjà pour
ce qui donne moins de moins d'objets
promotionnels on va dire envahi sans
encombre en est peut-être plus utile
maintenant ils donnent beaucoup de porte
clés de stylos ou de petits objets on va
dire utiles à la vie courante et les
gens ils ont plus tendance à les garder
et à moins légitime il yal'avant tours
il ya le pendant et l'après mail avant
l'avant tour c'est parce que le plus
gros a fait son a déjà fait plusieurs
rotations avec des déchets on essaye de
d'avoir toujours les sacs le plus vite
possible opa pour que pour éviter que
les gens achètent un bien sûr le tour
traverse régulièrement des sites classés
natura 2000 des espaces naturels très
fragile l'émergence des questions de
développement durable dans le débat
public a modifié les comportements des
spectateurs ils ont mis quand même
beaucoup dans les sacs poubelle où il ya
du sauvage un peu ils ont mis en sauveur
ils ont lésé des paquets là on
s'aperçoit que ça ça va beaucoup mieux
copie les gens je pense que ils ont
aussi leur mentalité qu'avant quand il
arrive dans la montagne il faut que ses
propres que c'est que c'est quand même
très très beau le paysage et ils se
disent qu'on va pas laisser ce à quoi on
va pas laisser ça là il ramasse
foutu trois mois quand ya pas de zoom
bien regroupée
plus tard dans la soirée les
organisateurs retrouve les élus locaux
autour d'un buffet ici aussi les
inondations ont provoqué des dégâts
considérables
alors les coureurs ont légué leur prime
d'étapes et le tour de france a fait un
don de 30 mille euros au département
sinistré hautes pyrénées et haute
garonne et entre deux bouchées le futur
parcours est sur toutes les lèvres lui
dévoiler le parcours du tour 2014
puisque ce sera le 23 octobre prochain
et jusqu'à les miens je vous êtes les
bienvenus vous parlez des gones rêve oui
oui michel où il conçoit bien sûr qu'ils
nous passerons par le tourmalet l'année
prochaine mais expliqué que la route
était complètement c'est vrai qu'elle
est équipée en dix endroits qu'elle
était arraché le tourmalet c'est le
premier géant du tour de france et nous
viendrons bien sûr l'année prochaine
pour le doré on est dans l'ordre du
symbole mais c'est aussi nous sommes le
tigre au delà du symbole le fait que à
esso et en particulier christian
prudhomme directeur du cyclisme a très
bien mesurer quelle est l importance du
traumatisme et comment à leur niveau
peuvent-ils nous aider à surmonter ce
traumatisme en 2014
les coureurs vont donc gravir une
nouvelle fois le tourmalet plus qu'un
symbole un gage de renaissance pour ce
territoire lourdement touchée car le
tour de france n'est pas qu'une simple
épreuve au creux de juillet mais une
course à l'ecoute des régions et des
terroirs et malgré les scandales le
dopage des attaques
le mythe perdure et la compétition
continue et c'est bien une des plus
belle carte de visite pour la france et
ses territoires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]